let's continue on the phones we'll go
next to our caller from the four seven
nine area code caller from four seven
nine what's your name were you calling
from and what's on your mind today my
name is Jacob I'm calling from Fort
Smith Arkansas how you doing David good
what's up what's going on well I got a
question about you know with jank user
and Kara kolinsky they face toe form
justice Democrats and also you know they
partnered with brand new Congress it was
Bernie with the him supporting course
from Medicare for all what do you think
is the possibility of that happening
within the next eight ten years or so I
mean do you think it's possible or do
you think that gonna be sooner or longer
listen I think if you're thinking that a
ten year time horizon
it's conceivably possible that there
might be Medicare for all at the federal
level I think the more likely path
towards some kind of universal coverage
would be it happening at the state level
and it's sad that you know Vermont was
actually going to be moving forward with
their state single-payer plan and it's
been completely derailed so my I always
try to have some optimism but at the
same time I am pretty cynical I would
love to say that in ten years we might
have something approximating Medicare
for all but I don't think it's I don't
think it's particularly likely that it
would come from the federal level if we
don't first see it come up from the
states so I think it would be a really
great thing to look at state
single-payer programs you know it's
unfortunate too even if Democrats did
win back majorities in the Senate and
the house you'd still probably have
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi at the
helm there and neither one of those
representatives support Medicare for all
at least in its current state yeah so I
think that there's there's some real
specific reasons why it's an uphill
battle but you know the other thing is
Jacob it's still okay because you can
negotiate from there right and part of
the problem I had with Obamacare was it
was a maybe we'd have a public option
but no we'll scratch that and we'll
start negotiating from something even to
the right and then what you get is you
know a couple a couple tens of millions
of new customers for four
for insurance companies let's start with
everybody should have health care and
negotiate from there so even if it's not
actually passed in 10 years I still
think that there's a lot of value to it
even though that it's so popular today
that you think you're still gonna take a
long time I hope I'm wrong I really hope
I'm wrong but when you consider
everything that would need to happen I
hope you're right and I hope to someday
have your optimism on it but I think
that we're going to need to see what I
would love to see is some state
single-payer programs proposed past and
piloted first see all right I appreciate
it thank you appreciate it as well